The Joe Rogan experience. How do you decide what you're going to ask people?
You just go on with the flow, do research and stuff. Cause I, I,
I really loved some of the questions you asked Kanye,
trying to remember what they were, but I mean,
do you sort of plan in advance or are you kinda just sorta up.
Because, well, with Kanye, we had talked about doing a podcast for a long time,
but I was worried that he was going to come off.
I remember your first question was, why do you want to do this? Right.
I just was when he was running for president, that was such a great question.
Cause it's like, you know, why do you want to run for president?
But everybody would ask that question, but it was just,
it was just right into it. It was just great. You know.
A fan of his music, I've always been a fan of his music. And I think that the,
the way he communicates his sort of manic style of thinking
and constantly creating and doing things, it's why he's so successful. I mean,
that's the,
there's this like stream of consciousness that he has is also why he's so
prolific as an artist. Like, I mean, he is, all of his albums are good.
He doesn't have a dud. You know,
you go from one album to the next and they're all like he's got this
dream of creative ideas that are constantly running through his head.
And he talks sometimes in these streams where they don't end,
he goes from one subject to the next subject.
And so I was curious as to like how I was gonna talk to him.
And I wanted to make sure that we can do it in a way where other people are
going to appreciate there's a great value and the way he thinks.
And then if you get it in sound bites or you get it in some weird thing where he
says something and people get mad at him and they blew him or something like
that, like you're missing who he really is, who he really is,
is him all day.
It's not him in this 32nd chunk where you don't like what he said, guess what?
He probably doesn't like what he said either. Okay, he's streaming.
He's just going, he's running with these thoughts and ideas,
but that's also why he can boil those thoughts and ideas down these amazing
songs. You know, like this is,
that's what I wanted to get out of him while we were talking because when people
were trying to medicate him and people were trying to, and I'm like, I, I don't,
if you have a choice between this medicated, overweight,
Kanye who doesn't get anything done or manic crazy, Kanye says wild.
You want manic? Crazy. Kanye is manic. Crazy.
Kanye is the one who makes amazing music and I've been around him.
He's a nice guy, man. He's a really genuinely nice guy.
And when the cameras are off, same things,
nice guy with all the staff and everybody he's cool. Like he's genuinely cool,
but whatever you want to call mental illness, that's the problem.
It's like when you call it mental illness, well, we'll,
you got to give it medicine. He's got mental illness.
You've got to give him medicine. Do you really?
Because that mental illness is making some pretty amazing, right? Like,
look at us, look at his catalog. Look at all the music he's made.
That's all because of mental illness. No,
that whatever you call an illness is a particular style of thinking that he has.
That's sort of non-linear and it's, it's wild and it's all over the place.
But it's also very funny.
I've found in that interview though, that, you know,
I've seen him interviewed quite a bit, but that was,
that was one where everything you said made a lot of sense.
He's certainly done a lot of
put a lot of thought into a lot of the stuff he was talking about with
everything from, you know, reorganizing the way civilization works. I mean,
I just, I, it takes a little bit of,
it takes a little bit of thinking to come up with how to reorganize the entire
way civilization works.
But that was one of the things that I thought was really good about the
interviews. You do get a chance to see, like,
this is not just a crazy person who buys his own. And by the way,
when he's like the braggy stuff that he kind of does talks to himself,
first of all, he's being honest about where he is.
He's sort of reaffirming who he is, but also he jokes around,
like he was joking around about it outside.
He was showing us this video that he had made for his wife for his wife's
birthday. And it was really emotional. It was very beautiful because he,
he made a, uh,
a hologram of her dad and he wrote the script for all
this. Oh yeah.
And he wrote the script for all the things that the hall ground was telling her.
It's, it's really intense. And you know,
you can do that now like that they can take your voice and for you and I,
it would be easy for them to do because there's hours and hours and hours of us
talking. So they would take this voice. God, imagine what they could do.
They already have theirs they've they used me as an example for one
of these companies in Canada,
they used me as an example for how well this deep fake technology works because
there's 1500 plus podcasts in me that are three hours
long. So he'd take these,
these sounds that come out of my mouth and then you can make me say anything,
literally anything, cause every noise that I'm capable of making I've made.
Right?
So you use this catalog of sounds that my voice can make.
And that's what he also did without hologram. Yeah. Because you know,
Robert Kardashian,
there's all the cases and all the different times he's been interviewed on
television.
There's a great catalog of his voice and you can have him speak to her.
Yeah. But even in then, like he has him say that, uh,
you know, in your genius genius husband,
but he was laughing when he said it and showed it to us. He was laughing.
He thought it was funny that he, he had them,
he had Robert Kardashians call him a genius, amazing genius husband.
He thought it was funny. Like, he's not just, it's not just ego.
It's not just crazy. It's also there's brilliance there.
He's a complicated person. It's nice to hear.
That because like, you know, it's interesting. I don't,
you know how the media can sort of reframe.
A person, right. And takeaway nuance. Yeah.
People are nuanced. Man. People are really complicated. You decide,
decide that a person is this person because of one sentence,
they said one time or because of one thing that they did where they maybe wish
they didn't or because of one concert they did where people booed them or what,
whatever you pick about Kanye that people decide he's this.
People just love to put someone in a box and categorize them and just decide
that they want to dismiss them.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere. But after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking you just go download Spotify much. Buh-bye
okay.